nico is with us from estonia hi nico how
are you
oh hello thank you how are you sir
better than i deserve
what part of estonia are you in part two
it's a very small city although the
second biggest city in estonia rachel
and i and our family visited talon a few
years ago or
it's talon is that how you pronounce it
yes yeah
beautiful beautiful city how can we help
i saw estonia and i said
not many people can probably say i have
been to your country nico
i've been to a store how can we help you
sir
uh me and my fiance are moving to us to
indiana notre dame for our phd degrees
both in the same department we are
debt-free we do not have any debt we
have
all our moving costs covered and we both
have fellowship
the thing is we will have some salary
left over every month
and we have no idea about american
economics or how can we invest or what
we should do with it
should we go ahead let's let me say that
we'll have about
2 000 left each month on the side after
eating
providing for shelter from everything
that and
what should we do should we plan to buy
a house maybe next year
or should we invest in a different way i
would love to listen to your advice
wow what do you what's your phd you're
studying
bioengineering i am building synthetic
hearts
wow wow so will you be when you finish
the phd will you be returning or will
you be staying
in the u.s i haven't made up my mind yet
but i think i will stay a little bit
longer to
for postdocs okay
well south bend is a beautiful town been
there a lot of times notre dame's a
fabulous campus so you've signed up for
the
a world-class ride there the um
if you're going to be there five years
or
longer buying a home is not a bad idea
if you're not going to be there five
years or longer it's questionable
all right i was thinking the money i'm
going to pay for rent which is about
1200 a month
i can just pay it for mortgage and even
if i don't stay
there at the end i can sell the house
and
get some of those money back instead of
well
you won't necessarily unless you stay
five years we don't know if the
typically the house will not go up
enough in value
and you've got to make sure you can get
the house sold houses you know right now
houses are selling like crazy the real
estate market's quite hot
but a few years ago you couldn't give
one away so um
you know you don't want to get into a
home if you're not going to be there
five years because your trade out for
rent is not one for one
because you can turn around and lose
money on the house and make you wish you
had rented
uh if you're not gonna if you're only
gonna be there be in the house two or
three years or something
and the south bend market's a solid
market uh there's nothing wrong with it
i you know it's not a bad place to own
real estate but all real estate needs to
be purchased with a five year window or
longer
other than that i would just pile up the
cash because nico a pile of cash just
gives you lots of options
and then as you decide where you're
going to stay and where you're going to
be that pile of cash can be applied
wherever you are
and that that's true in any economy yeah
absolutely would you
would you recommend him investing if
he's not gonna be here five years or
longer
yeah if you're gonna be if you want to
play if you want to do like an index
fund and park some of that money that's
fine
uh but uh the the big thing the money is
going to give you that's going to be
more than anything else is just the
flexibility
which to move to another city if you're
going to stay in the u.s to move back to
estonia if you're going back
you know apollo cash just gives you
options and sometimes those options are
more valuable than what you might have
made on an investment yeah it's good
and so certainly real estate will be a
mistake if you're only going to be there
a couple years
um most of the time i mean there's a few
times you get out hold but i just i love
real estate but it's not a short-term
play
and it's not a play it's not a trade-off
for rent everybody's got this thing
about you know
versus rent it it really doesn't work
out that way except in the long haul
short range it does not work out that
way